[Music]
my name is Jeff Koons I'm an artist I
have live at work in New York some of my
better known artworks would be Michael
Jackson and bubbles my stainless steel
rabbit balloon dog I tried to be open to
everything I don't make any judgments
about everything and eventually I'll
start to find meaning in certain objects
certain images and then eventually I'll
realize that I want to make a gesture
with that and to make an artwork so that
whole process that could be two years of
just following my interest and then once
I decide to make something probably
another two years in the production and
the realization of the object to do that
sometimes I have to work with other
people I have a studio and I have about
a hundred and thirty people and it's
broken up into different sections I have
a 3d department I have a 2d area
I have sculpture I'm the captain of this
ship so I'm really responsible for
everything you know in pricing an
artwork you have to take into account
the cost of manufacturing something
which can really be quite high in the
past I've actually lost money on some of
my works initially like on my balloon
dogs I lost money because I thought the
production would be less than what it
ended up to be the more polarities that
you can have in a work the more dimma
Tate's life itself
I enjoyed the smooth surface I enjoy a
reflective surface because it defines at
the location you know when you have like
a gazing ball that's reflecting in 360
degrees it affirms that your
participation is necessary because when
you move you know the abstraction the
reflection changes in that bone
I want people really to be able to have
a greater sense of their own potential
through interacting with my work
you